et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
sébastien chenu bonjour j'ai aussi
beaucoup d'être avec nos porte parole de
marine le pen la candidate du
rassemblement national merci beaucoup
d'être avec non détention pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale et
votre presse régionale sébastien chenu
c'est la voix du nord bonjour lumière
écuyers bonjour oriane bonjour monsieur
chenu jeu monsieur on va comment on va
évidemment parler du programme de marine
le pen de votre campagne mais d'abord
sur l'actualité et l'ukraine vous avez
vu évidemment ces images de massacres
dans la région de kiev est ce que vous
dites ce matin que vladimir poutine doit
rendre des comptes et doit être traduit
devant un tribunal international
ce qu'on dit d'abord c'est que l'onu
doit déclencher suite à ces images
monstrueuse épouvantable sur lequel
effectivement je pense que nous sommes
tous saisis d'effroi le duo a
immédiatement déclenché une enquête nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui les éléments que
moi je fais confiance de temps en temps
ça arrive à emmanuel macron qui nous dit
qu'il a des éléments qui accable la
russie si tel était le cas et bien il y
aura des conséquences d'abord peut-être
rappeler tout de suite notre ambassadeur
le faire revenir et puis la russie à
travers vladimir poutine va avoir des
heures difficiles devant elle quand il
s'agira de rendre des comptes si
effectivement tout ça et confirme la
grappe et son ambassadeur mais ce qu'il
faut pas décidé de nous d'un nouveau
de nouvelles sanctions à son encontre
bien sûr bien sûr il faut appuyer sur
les sanctions avec une réserve que vous
connaissez un que nous avons toujours
exprimé oui au maximum de sanctions au
maximum de sanctions à partir du moment
où elle n'impacte pas les français
essayez leur pouvoir d'achat d'accord
c'est pas simple mais ça veut dire mais
encore une coupe et pas le robinet qui
coule à l'heure actuelle de l de gaz et
de pétrole et qui pourtant rapportent à
à vladimir poutine par l'état russe et
sur 800 millions par jour non mais il ya
d'autres façons d'ailleurs de
sanctionner financièrement la russie par
exemple vous avez vu que la russie est
doté d'un fonds souverain on pourrait
faire en sorte que ce fonds souverains
ne puisse pas
j'allais dire se développer sur l'europe
en tous les cas bloquer un certain
nombre d'avoirs oui encore des
possibilités de sanctions sur le gaz ce
qui est très particulier c'est que ça
revient à nous mêmes nous tirer une
balle dans le pied donc moi ce que je
veux c'est que la russie soit ramené
soit amené à la table des négociations
pour qu'on sorte par la voie
diplomatique
mais c'est ce que fait le président de
la république les plus cons plus
question d'entente avec la russie je me
permets de vous rappeler votre propre
programme présidentiel qui était celle
d'une entente avec avec la russie il te
sort en cire de l'otan qualifiée
d'organisation
il insiste vous dit deux choses fausses
d'abord annoncé jean n'avons jamais
parlé sortir de l'otan nous avons parlé
de sortir du commandement intégré de
l'otan ce qui n'est pas pareil et je
veux vous expliquer pourquoi si vous le
souhaitez nous sortir de l'otan donc non
hélas
ce que vous avez que vous avez péché
dans votre programme présidentiel l'otan
d' organisation belliciste bien sûr vous
parliez d'une entente avec la russie
mais tout ceci est mis de côté d'or et
nos cieux il y aura évidemment demain
encore des relations avec la russie il y
aura un après de la divers poutine la
russie ne va pas disparaître et
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron parle avec
vladimir poutine et il a raison
puisqu'il faut qu'il négociait
diplomatiquement une sortie de cette
guerre parce que si c'est pas la
diplomatie ce sera la guerre donc il ya
aujourd'hui parler dans une architecture
de sécurité européenne c'était encore
une fois ce qui était dans votre
programme présidentiel est-ce que encore
une fois à l'heure actuelle on peut
envisager d'avoir une entente avec la
russie pour construire la sécurité
européenne mais évidemment que nous
aurons une entente avec la russie que
nous avons une entente avec la chine
demain parce que parfois les grandes
puissances même si elle nous déplaisent
fortement elles sont parfois des alliés
parfois des concurrents parfois des
adversaires et il se trouve que je pense
que la russie demain peut être un allié
un concurrent est un adversaire il faut
donc parler avec car si on ne parle pas
avec la russie demain je parle pas de
l'individu vladimir poutine sincèrement
vladimir poutine
est un type qui aujourd'hui à toutes les
a tous les symptômes d'un dictateur mais
si nous ne parlons pas avec vladimir
poutine aujourd'hui pour faire cesser
cette guerre et demain avec le pouvoir
russe eh bien nous livrerons la russie
dans les bras de la chine alors si c'est
ce qu'on veut faire je pense que ça aura
des conséquences terribles donc oui je
pense qu'il faut parler avec la russie
et avec ses dirigeants comme nous
parlons d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'états
dans le monde qui ne sont pas dirigées
par de gentils démocrates par de gentils
républicain mais parce que c'est notre
intérêt c'est l'intérêt de la france et
c'est même l'intérêt du monde parce que
ces facteurs de paix que de parler
plutôt que de guerroyer ici j'ai mis un
petit nez pour être intégré dans le
concert des nations pour vos chansons à
écouter le sincèrement j'ai pas d'idée
je peux pas être plus présent la
république est le président de la
république on n'a pas d'information mais
il semble aujourd'hui que la douleur
poutine s éloigne lui même de plus en
plus de ce qui en fait un partenaire de
dialogue l'homme s'enferment dans
quelque chose maintenant il faut en tous
les cas continuer à discuter avec parce
que c'est la démocratie c'est la
diplomatie pardon qui peut nous faire
sortir de cette guerre je veux pas
tellement d'autres solutions l'autre
solution c'est quoi c'est entre en
guerre avec la russie je crois pas que
ce soit ni l'intérêt de la france ni
l'intérêt de l'europe le premier lautrec
notre actualitté on va avancer
sur le cabinet de conseil le parc
national financé a révélé qu'il avait
ouvert une enquête la semaine dernière
contre le cabinet contre mckinsey pour
blanchiment aggravé de fraude fiscale
suite au rapport du sénat qui a révélé
qu on m insee ne paient pas d'impôts en
france qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'ouverture de cette enquête je trouve
que je pense que nous sommes devant un
scandale immense scandale mckinsey
macron dit plusieurs choses d'abord dit
qu'un président de la république a livré
à des puissances étrangères à des
industries des entreprises étrangères
une partie
de données françaises en leur demandant
en retour et contre des sommes des
espèces sonnantes et trébuchantes de
réfléchir à l'avenir de ce que doit être
le système de retraite français de ce
que doit être la distribution à des
professions de foi aux élections de ce
que doit être on a vu aussi un dossier
sur les 1000 premiers jours de l'enfant
et donc il a délivré à des entreprises
étrangères de l'information et en
échange de cela mckinsey a dit au
président voilà comment vous devez
réformer le système de retraite français
je trouve ça choquant je trouve que
c'est gravissime et je trouve que
d'ailleurs on a une très haute fonction
d'une très bonne foi haute fonction
publique dans le pays qui pourrait faire
ces travaux là je trouve que ça ne
répond à aucune logique républicaine le
réseau national à haut pouvoir coupe
tous les horreurs robinet concernant les
cabinets de conseil privé mais en cours
n'a besoin de cabinet de conseil privé
étranger pour pouvoir nous guider sur la
réforme des retraites parce que vous
êtes capable de m'expliquer
pas davantage d'ailleurs enfin je veux
dire je ne vois pas en quoi on peut
avoir besoin pour voir un aspect
technique il ya des compétences qui ne
sont pas
en mission publique n'a pas sur les
services informatiques est ce que vous
en colère des fonctionnaires au lieu de
prendre avec ses associés sur la
compétence informatique ponctuelle on
peut faire appel à un cabinet français
pour nous aider mais enfin c'est pas ça
le coeur du problème c'est pas ça dont
je viens vous parler il n'est pas là le
scandale faut pas essayer de déplacer le
regard sur
deux
ils ne payent pas d'impôts d'ailleurs
mckinsey a menti devant la
représentation nationale là aussi il
faudra en parler mais le recours à des
cabinets étrangers financé pour
plusieurs milliards je vous le rappelle
pour simplement prendre en main le
cerveau du président de la république
qui cabinet qui avait d'ailleurs
participé à la campagne présidentielle
d'emmanuel macron là aussi un espèce de
conflit d'intérêt permanent et bien avec
des pas mal de gens dire dans les
cabinets ministériels qui viennent
autour des madame accros de chez
mckinsey et là encore conflit d'intérêt
permanent et bien non seulement avec
nous c'est fini mais c'est scandaleux
c'est tout à fait ce qu'on aime quand
vous pensez de boris cyrulnik était
sollicité par le gouvernement pour
réfléchir aux 1000 premiers jours de
l'enfant et qu'en parallèle françoise
elle bossait le gouvernement a fait
bosser mckinsey pour des milliers
d'euros des centaines de milliers
d'euros pour le même dossier sincèrement
il ya un problème et un scandale
autre actualité c'est celle de lier à
samuel pâtit la famille de sam et le
bâti l'enseignant assassiné à porter
plainte un concernant le considérant que
l'administration était fautive et
n'avait pas su protéger le professeur
estime que des fautes ont été ont été
commises tant du côté de l'éducation
nationale du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur est ce qu'il ya eu faute
selon vous de l'état mais l'état doit
rendre des comptes mais on le voit dans
la sphère sa malle pâti tout comme on le
voit dans l'affairé yvan colonna arrêté
on voit un état qui probablement
dysfonctionne à certains moments alors
ces dysfonctionnements nécessite des
enquêtes moi je comprends la position
des familles je comprends la position de
la famille de sam elle pâtissait vivant
que le la pour lequel j'ai pas beaucoup
de tendresse à vous me le permettrais
mai yvan colonna qui a été condamné pour
avoir fait assassiner dans le dos un
préfet de la république mais ça en dit
long sur le dif ce dysfonctionnement de
l'état je veux dire quand yvan colonna
est tué par un jihadiste en prison ça
pose un problème
enfin écoutez ça pose un problème de
suivi ça pose un djihadiste qui était
j'ai cru comprendre auxiliaires de
l'administration pénitentiaire alors
qu'il était classé comme un individu
particulièrement dangereux agir oui ça
pose des problèmes et quand ça pose des
problèmes l'état doit rendre des comptes
à un mot juste sur la corse on a compris
votre position sur la plainte de
l'affairé colonna mais est-ce que si
marine le pen est élue elle pousserait
poursuivra les discussions engagées par
le gouvernement avec les élus de l'île
sur la question de l'autonomie non mais
discuter avec les élus de l'île sur
l'avenir de la corse c'est nécessaire
les élus de l'île ils sont élus par
définition discuter avec eux me semble
nécessaire
et pas sur l'autonomie marine le pen sur
un ton peu aller vers un statut qu'ils
soient particuliers d'une collectivité
locale française avec une partie des
particularités je dirais en outre-mer il
a exigé que déjà donc on peut regarder
pour effectivement adapté - sauf moi ce
que je crois c'est qu'il y à deux
paramètres et marine le pen l'a exprimé
dans corse matin hier de paramètres c1
le rétablissement de la sécurité et de
la paix en corse il n'est pas possible
que dès qu'il y ait ce climat de
violence permanente et on ne négocie pas
sous la violence donc ça c'est la
première chose à faire la deuxième chose
c'est que la corse ne pourra pas
évidemment répondre aux difficultés que
causent à l'insularité difficultés de
pouvoir d'achat
difficultés du coût de la vie et c'est
du logement etc que par une raie une
implantation d'un certain nombre
d'industries sur le territoire de
départementale des deux départements de
corse de cette collectivité
d'industrie qui correspondent à la corse
et qui permettent simplement que la
corse ne vivent pas uniquement du
tourisme parce qu'il est là le problème
les jus ce que vous mettez fin aux
violences parce que là il ya une
violence et à ne discuter sur la
question de l'autonomie
voulait pas être mais c'est aussi le
rôle des élus corses qui ont aidé et qui
sont en place aujourd'hui qui ont des
relations des relais dans ce territoire
qui permettent je crois d'entamer le
dialogue enfin je veux dire c'est aux
élus corses de faire cesser ces
violences mais les élus corses bien sûr
doivent s'impliquer là dedans et puis
l'état ne peut pas céder on peut pas
ouvrir une discussion sur l'autonomie
mais surtout pas en plus suite aux
violences enfin on a vu encore des
violences hier soir c'est pas possible
on va parler de votre programme pouvoir
d'achat évidemment c'est la principale
préoccupation des français alors dans
votre programme il ya des mesures sur la
baisse des taxes sur l'énergie mais il
ya une question qui va se poser c'est la
hausse des prix de l'alimentaire est ce
que vous êtes pour un chèque
alimentaires non écoutez moi je crois
qu'il faut des mesures pérennes et on le
voit les français souffrent de sept de
ses dix victoires d'achat depuis déjà
assez longtemps en réalité c'est pas la
guerre en ukraine qui a fait plonger le
pouvoir d'achat des français ça fait
longtemps que les français ont vu leur
pouvoir d'achat notamment d'abord sur
l'énergie sur l'essence mais tout ça
c'était déjà avant la guerre en une
figure
sur l'alimentation marine le pen a
exprimé une proposition tant que
l'inflation serait reparti à la hausse
elle souhaite qu'il y ait une tva qui
soit abaissé à 0 sur un panier de 100
produits de première
dont qu ça c'est une mesure concrète sur
mesure que nous pouvons tenir c'est une
mesure qui est facile d'usurper rennes
ce n'est pas une mesure pérenne c'est au
bout pour limite le temps que
c'est le moment mais le gardien des
secrets de la nous amène la version
sirène mais nous avons des mesures
pérennes parce que je vous explique
l'idée des chèques que fait le
gouvernement pour payer finalement des
taxes me semble être un non sens
économique coûter très cher beaucoup
plus finalement que des mesures pérennes
on l'a vu avec notamment le chèque
énergie et un total de je le dis non
sens économique enfin les messieurs
chers les chèques pour payer des taxes
et belleville a baissé à baisser la tva
c'est en effet ça peut ça peut se
comprendre mais ça veut dire que dès
lors que vous la remettez vous assumez
devoir remonter les prix assez brutal
aux attentes l'inflation dans les temps
que l'inflation ne monte pas c'est
justement un correctif de l'inflation
quand l'inflation revient à son niveau
habituel eh bien on remet une tva au
niveau que nous connaissons sauf sur
l'énergie où nous avons effectivement
une mesure pérenne de baisse à 5,5 de
l'énergie parce que nous considérons que
c'est un c'est une on ne peut pas vivre
sans se transformer sans se chauffer et
c'est donc là c'est une mesure pérenne
qui est un coup mais là encore un coût
qui est probablement aujourd'hui moins
important que cette démultiplication de
chèques vous avez 12 milliards 12
milliards donc c'est une baisse de le
taxer de façon pérenne le gouvernement a
promis d'augmenter le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires c'est emmanuel macron
intérêts et lieu est ce que cette mesure
vous la tiendrais c'est marine le pen
oui mais écoutez moi je veux dire
aujourd'hui le gouvernement c'est un peu
ce zigzag permanent ils promettent tous
qu'ils n'ont pas tenu enfin je veux dire
ça devient presque grotesque nous on a
promis et on a souhaité par exemple une
ré indexation des retraites si elle
avait déjà eu lieu les retraités ne
serait pas dans la situation que nous
connaissons donc sur les fonctionnaires
elle nous allons prendre un certain
nombre d'engagements aussi pour que leur
situation et leur statut soit avantagé
pour qu'il soit mieux rémunéré mais ce
que nous souhaitons ce sont des mesures
qui ont une cohérence d'ensemble à des
augmentations du point d'indicé
mais nous ne sommes pas fermés cette
augmentation du canada ne sommes pas
fermés à cela mais nous allons faire
d'abord aussi avec un budget contraint
je vous rappelle que la dette a explosé
sous les manuels macron nous voulons
nous redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français nous voulons mieux rémunérés là
encore de façon pérenne les
fonctionnaires et les français vous avez
vu que nous avons fait des propositions
notamment d'augmentation des salaires
de 10% pour ceux qui jusqu'à 3 fois le
smic donc là nous aurons une négociation
importante avec les entreprises à mener
parce que je pense que cette
augmentation de salaire
évidemment le public sera aussi traité
de la même façon nous pensons par
exemple dans le milieu hospitalier il
n'est pas possible de voir les aides
soignants si mal rémunérés nous pensons
que les professeurs sont mal rémunérés
donc oui effectivement nous souhaitons
que les français soient mieux rémunérés
privés ou publics et pas pour les
collectivités locales par exemple les
collectivités locales sont des français
qui travaillent
sur l'issue du programme oui je voulais
vous parler de programme de marine le
pen prévoit l'expulsion des étrangers
sont sans emploi depuis un an ou encore
l'octroi du rsa aux seuls étrangers y
ont travaillé durant au moins cinq ans
est-ce que c'est des dispositions qui
s'appliqueront réfugiés ukrainien et
notamment beaucoup de femmes avec
enfants qui sont qui sont là en france
mais les réfugiés une craignent un ne
sont pas là ce n'est pas de
l'immigration on à venir ce sont des
réfugiés de guerre sont des gens et moi
j'en ai rencontré dans le nord des
familles nordistes ont accueilli des
ukrainiens blessés sont des étrangers
sur le territoire fini ils sont aidés
ponctuellement et ils ont vocation à
repartir et eux mêmes nous le disent
d'ailleurs nous on ne veut pas rester en
france et la guerre est
ce que vous les traités comme des
immigrés économiques ce ne sont pas si
je suis une immigration votre programme
ce sont des étrangers ou même titre que
le des immigrés ou réfugiées quel que
soit leur statut ça veut dire que vous
mélangez de choses mais vous mélangez le
statut de réfugié statut de réfugié de
guerre et vous mélangez l'immigration
économique de gens qui nous parlons
aussi de gens nous parlons aussi par
exemple des des immigrés en situation
irrégulière qui ont accès à un certain
nombre de droits dans notre pays parce
que c'est fini cette action n'est pas
faite dans votre programme c'est pour ça
oui mais parce que au moment où on
arrivait le programme on n'imaginait pas
forcément qu'il est réfugié d'ukraine
qui arrivent non mais des réglages il y
en a depuis quelques années des réfugiés
d'ukraine sont aidés donc
rusé réfugiés ukrainien peu importe des
réfugiés ne font pas partie des
dérèglements de la réglementation que
vous souhaitez mettre on va partir du
moment où ils ont vocation à repartir
ils sont aidés de façon très ponctuelle
vous avez bien compris enfin faut pas
prendre les choses par le petit bout de
la lorgnette
c'est juste pour
ceux qui posent leur glace ce sont des
gens qui sont sur notre territoire pour
des raisons économiques depuis plusieurs
années et qui ne contribue pas pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux pas tous
d'ailleurs pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux aux cotisations sociales et
qui bénéficie de la solidarité nationale
cette solidarité nationale elle
s'exprimera au demain pour les nationaux
d'accord
sur autre question c'est ce que c'est
qu'ils étaient 2 qui est dans votre
programme officiel et qui pourtant avait
droit de été retirés vous proposé en
octobre 2019 d'interdire le voile et la
kippa dans l'intégralité de l'espace
public
c'est finalement un argument qui a été
retenu de retirer d'un programme
officiel pour se concentrer uniquement
sur le voile islamique
pourquoi avoir retiré dernière chance à
laquelle j'invite effectivement vous en
tenir aux programmes de 2022 puisque ces
élections présidentielles de 2022 oui
mais bon très simple nous nous
considérons que le voile islamique c'est
un marqueur très fort de l'islamisme en
france c'est à dire que c'est un acteur
un marqueur politique d'une idéologie
que nous combattons et que nous
souhaitons éradiquée dans notre
territoire l'islamisme l'islamisme pas
l'islam l'islamisme mais à partir du
moment où le voile est l'expression de
l'islamisme eh bien nous allons faire
voter une loi qui définira ce qu'est
l'islamisme qui avait quel que soit le
toit là on est bien des points le
bienfait du foulard jusque voilà
exactement et nous considérons qu'il
n'est pas possible de porter ce marqueur
islamistes dans l'espace public les
personnes qui portent un voile bah oui
les gens qui sortira c'est en tire des
musulmanes en france on est à l'écouté
bien entendu ils sont des islamistes
bien nous inviterons les personnes qui
portent ce voile à le retirer car nous
considérons que le voile est un marqueur
je pense que il
je pense qu'il ya des femmes qui sont
obligées de le porter qui se sentent
obligés de le porter sous une certaine
pression et qui ne sont pas des
islamistes évidemment évidemment autre
question alors c'est vrai que quand on
regarde votre programme préférence
nationale fin du droit du sol
présomption de légitime défense pour les
membres des forces de l'ordre sur la
sécurité l'immigration en fait rien rien
ne nous distingue vraiment des ré que
d'eric zemmour qui suis ici je vais vous
dire pourquoi ils métier mais je vais
vous dire toutes ses phrases une chose
fondamentale qui nous distingue nous
nous attaquons à l'immigration pas aux
immigrés nous nous attaquons au
phénomène de l'immigration phénomène
migratoire qui était si mal gérée dans
notre pays et qu'il est tout petit
devant
600 personnes les changements bien son
etc je suis bien d'accord avec vous mais
c'est le jeu ce que je vous ai ce que je
vous ai cités en tout cas et vous est
parfaitement similaire à vos deux à
votre programme et ce qu'ils ne sont en
fait pas finalement un partenaire
naturel pour vous au second tour écouter
eric zemmour a été je crois un candidat
qui a divisé le corps national vous
voyez bien il ya des points de
convergence ya des points de divergence
des jeunes vous en citer un qui à mon
avis est fondamentale mais eric zemmour
est plus beaucoup plus libéral
économiquement beaucoup plus beaucoup
moins sociale dans son approche des
choses c'est une évidence donc il ya des
points de convergence des points de
divergence il se déterminera au second
tour mais vous souhaitez des disques
par entrer dans des discussions de
boutiques au film adèle macron va pas
aller discuter avec mélenchon jadot
pécresse je pense mais quand même
elle est à vous améliorer on n'aura pas
combien eu par exemple nicolas dupont
aignan 2017 ça n'existait pas ses
responsabilités
nous notre porte et notre main entre
humains étendu notre porte est ouverte à
tous les électeurs ceux de derry et moi
évidemment ceux de valérie pécresse
évidemment ceux de jean luc mélenchon 7
fabien
vous savez c'est la logique de la vème
république c'est la rencontre entre une
candidate en l'occurrence et les
français pas par l'intermédiaire des
partis politiques je veux me le disait
si vous avez discuté avec nicolas
n'avait pas porté
commun entre marine le pen et eric
zemmour marine le pen en dialogue direct
avec les français mais ça ne fait quand
même penser à une marine le pen parlait
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale donc
dans un gouvernement d'union nationale
on pourrait imaginer peut-être que eric
zemmour et sa place je crois qui tarda
pas très envie vigilance gouvernement
bien sûr c'est très intéressant et je
vous réponds pour d'abord emmanuel
macron quand vous avez découvert jean
michel blanquer agnès buzyn mairie
pénicaud je pense que comme moi vous
étiez dans la télévision et vous ai dit
qu'ils sont ces gens et puis on les a
découverts ils sont entrés dans la
lumière il était dans l'entourage des
manuels macron personnel et
connaissaient ils sont devenus ils ont
acquis en notoriété à travers leurs
fonctions c'est pareil chez marine le
pen est belle macro n'avait pas
communiqué son gouvernement marine le
pen de cominar et communiquera pas son
goût la
liste
il y aura même une majorité de gens
d'otages grand cas de la série les deux
villes les deux de georges c'est bien
droite nous espérons bien nous parlons
avec des gens de la gauche
chevènementiste nous parlons avec des
gens vous allez l'addip 2 0 j'ai cru
qu'on mange lui ou des gens qui sont
dans sa philosophie d'ailleurs
écouter vu les gens aujourd'hui que
rencontrent marine le pen les gens que
nous rencontrons matin midi et soir je
peux vous dire que la question se sera
pas celle
du choix enfin c'est du trop plein nous
avons des compétences bien entendu il
n'y a qu'un
pas un jour sans que nous ne parlions à
des personnalités ou de la société
civile ou du monde politique et qui ne
soient pas des gens du rassemblement
national et qu'ils aient envie tout
simplement de nous aider à redresser la
france qui a des républicains et à des
personnalités politiques des
républicains qui vous ont dit si mal
les membres de marche vous aussi
contacté ses il y a des gens qui ont été
proches des modèles macron ou qui
aujourd'hui sont officiellement proches
des malades macron et qui considèrent
qu'une réduction des monnaies de macron
serait probablement un drame comme tout
je vais pas vous donner les noms parce
que je ne voudrais pas les gêner eux
mêmes vous serez candidat aux
législatives
j'ai pas encore annoncer des choses il y
a peu de suspense sur le fait que
connaissait l'attachement que j'ai à ma
circonscription il ya peu de suspense
sur le fait que je ne le serai pas
est-ce que là il y aura des alliances
avec les républicains avec eric zemmour
avec nos collègues et moi je vous savez
j'ai toujours considéré
comme nous on a toujours considéré que
nos candidatures étaient des
candidatures d'union et sont des
candidatures d' union nationale pour
former une majorité présidentielle
autour de marine le pen donc là encore
tous ceux qui sont d'accord avec nous
sur la méthode sur les propositions qui
sont les nôtres sont les bienvenus on
n'est pas des gens sectaire on ne
gouverne pas comme emmanuel macron avec
mc kinsey et une bande de copains mais à
gauche et à droite c'est pas malin en
même temps façon rassemblement national
non parce que ça pète et en même temps
avec les manades mcc en réalité c'était
le pire de la gauche et le pire de la
droite un gouvernement d'union nationale
vous savez ça résonne un peu comme le
conseil national de la résistance ça
résonne un peu comme l'idée de vue
d'unir des français de bonne volonté
pour redresser le pays merci sébastien
josse merci beaucoup d'avoir été note /
parole de marine le pen candidate du
rassemblement national et on va
maintenant accueillir le dernier
candidat qu'on reçoit durant ces deux
dernières semaines c'est jean lassalle
fils à prendre votre
[Musique]